Ginger Spice is incredible to choose a
superior Spice Girl is insane my
favorite growing up was always Baby
Spice but to choose one above of the all
five it's not it's not even fair
no thank you I'll move over to disagree
with you okay we'll turn the cameras off
here do you secretly have a favorite
listen you can have a favorite without
oh Posh is your favorite yeah
really
what do you think the other person's
spice goals Persona would be Hulk spice
Sporty Spice Sporty Spice are you
insane no you're Posh Spice I am kind of
yeah oh God that's so rude I know who
are you of the five yeah you're all five
mixed into one stop it all
spice you're my little all